jordan mcpherson who covers the marlins
for the miami herald kind enough to join
us uh yesterday at this time and
here he is again joining us today you
were in philadelphia yesterday at this
time
where are you now jordan uh i'm back
home in
broward county sunrise to be specific
yeah i came got back on
late yesterday okay where do we stand
with marlins baseball
uh as of right now obviously their game
yesterday against the baltimore orioles
was postponed their game today is also
postponed which makes sense considering
they're still in philadelphia
and baltimore flew back from miami to
baltimore
late last night a tentative plan is if
their testing results
are at an acceptable level by mlb
they'll be able to bust over to
baltimore on wednesday
to play their two series game there
wednesday and thursday
obviously only the players who tested
negative would be going over all
anybody who testifies is still going to
be quarantined in philadelphia
are they able to bring up players they
have a you know
another 30 players that are available to
them from the minor leagues are those
players going to be brought up to take
the place of those who have tested
positive
that would be correct they have 30
players at their alternate training site
down in jupiter florida
and they're also looking at some veteran
free agents or
some other players who are on the open
market design they added two pick two
relief pitchers
uh josh d smith not to be confused with
the josh a smith who was already
in their player pool and justin shaffer
they claimed both of them from the reds
uh yesterday afternoon what have we
learned
in the last 24 hours about what happened
over the weekend with the marlins
uh there's still a lot of uncertainty
there's been no specifics about their
test results from their latest round
which they did about
10 at some point between 10 and 10 30 on
monday those tests take
anywhere from 12 to 24 hours to come
back
we're still at the tail end of that
window of finding out
if any uh there are any other additional
positives on top of
the working they found out since they
got to philadelphia in terms of
where it originated there's still a lot
of unknowns
rob manfred said on mlb network
yesterday that
the league has theories but nothing
definitive but
it's really there are a few spots
obviously atlanta from their exhibition
game seems to be
a focal point that a lot of people are
going to especially considering
both the braves main catchers had
symptoms even though they didn't test
positive
for coven 19 and the morrow play two
exhibition games there
so whether it was the braves passing
tomorrow into marlins passing into the
braves we still know where the exact
origin was
but it looks like even though
the atlanta atlanta those games seems to
be
some sort of a breaking out point
uh before i let you go i curious who
knew
about this decision to play that game on
sunday even though they knew players had
tested positive
did don mattingly know why are they
leaving it up to
a player to make the decision to go out
and play a baseball game jordan
well to add on to that a little bit uh
rob manfred said
said on his interview yesterday that the
league was aware of the positive test
they did contact tracing to see if
they're
anybody who on the team who could be
potentially exposed
which his clarification and according to
what he said the cdc guidelines were
just being a teammate just being in the
clubhouse doesn't necessarily mean
you're potentially exposed
how much we can actually agree on that
is
up for debate but they said that they
found a about a handful of players who
may have been potentially exposed they
held all of those players in the hotel
and then the decision was made that it
was safe to play the game
if everybody else on the marlins were
okay with it and obviously
the players and man and don mattingly
were okay with it enough for them to
play
well good luck jordan i'm not sure where
your travels are going to take you but
hopefully you're headed to baltimore and
we appreciate your time
thank you very much yeah my plans to
leave for baltimore first thing tomorrow
morning
jordan mcpherson he covers the marlins
for the miami herald